Welcome aboard and thanks for flying with Delta.
Our first priority on every flight is safety.
So before we depart, I'll be giving a brief safety presentation.
Be sure all carry-on items are securely stowed in an overhead bin.
And ensure your mobile phones and electronic devices are turned off.
If you're seated at an emergency exit,...
...please review the responsibilities on the emergency exit seating, oh.
Please keep your seat belt fastened in case we experience unexpected rough air.
Smoking is not allowed on any Delta flight,...
...and federal law prohibits tampering with, disabling, or destroying a restroom smoke detector.
Please take a moment to find the exits closest to you.
And remember, they might be behind you.
Life vests are located under the seats, under your seat in the economy cabin.
Be sure your seat is upright, your aisle armrests are lowered, and your tray table is, ugh.
And all carry-on items are properly stowed.
Please let us know if you have any questions.
Sit back, relax and enjoy the flight.